اعتمد المجلس الاقتصادي والاجتماعيه للامم
المتحده قرارا صغته الولايات المتحده
اسقاط عضويه ايران في لجنه الامم المتحده
المعنيه بوضع المراه للفتره المتبقيه من
ولايتها والتي تستمر حتى عام 2026 اقل
المندوب الايراني لدى الامم المتحده امير
سعيد ان اخرج ايران من اللجنه المعنيه
بالمراه هو اجراء غير قانونيه ويشكل
السابق خطيره تقود سياده القانون في
منظومه الامم المتحده واضاف ان كل
الروايات التي اسقت في هذا القرار ملفقه
وشطانيا
تجوزي كويس
طلبوا الولايات المتحده غير قانوني تماما
لان اعضاء المجلس يدركون انه لا توجد
سابقه في ممارسه المجلس لانهاء مشاركه عضو
المنتخب في لجنه وظيفيه لاي سبب مزعوم ولا
تدعمه قواعد واجراءات المجلس على الرغم من
ذلك يعتزم عضو واحد وهو عضو متنمر ومشهور
ميثاق الامم المتحده والقانون الدولي
متابعه الطلبه غير القانوني بعزل عضو
منتخب من اللجنه فقط على اساس الدعاءات لا
اساس لها وحجج ملفقه من خلال روايات ملفقه
وشيطانيه تشكل بدورها سابقه خطيره وتقود
سياده القانون في منظمه الامم المتحده
وقد يستنكر المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني تصويت لاي صالح
قرار لازاله ايران من لجنه وضع المراه في
الامم المتحده وقال ان القرار بدعه سياسيه
ويفتقر للوجه القانونيه ويتعارض مع ميثاق
الامم المتحده ثم بضبط
مطالب سياسيه احاديه واضاف في بيان الله
ان واشنطس علي زعزعه استقرار ايران واعتبر
انها من اكبر منتهي في حقوق المراه في
ايران عبر فرض العقوبات الاحاديه حسب وصفه